well tens of thousands of foreigners are
helping the ukrainian fight uh ukrainian
president zielinski has set up what he
calls an international legion for
volunteers from abroad some countries
have urged their nationals not to join
the conflict threatening them with legal
action if they do
others are allowing their citizens to
volunteer dw's brigitte shulker caught
up with some would-be fighters on their
way to the combat zone
this is anatoli from finland it's not
his real name we meet him at the polish
train station trimester
packed with equipment and protective
gear anatoly is waiting to board the
train to ukraine to join the
fight me it was the right thing to do as
a human being
like part of the solidarity movement
i
strongly feel that i can
contribute
by going
he was studying art and design when he
decided to answer ukraine's call for
foreign fighters
with five years experience as an
instructor in the finnish defense force
he's eager to share his knowledge with
ukrainians who lack combat experience
they do have the manpower what they need
uh
in my opinion
instructors
uh team leaders uh
to get people
through the pipeline the training
pipeline
and especially with the western weapon
systems how to use them
effectively
over the past couple of days we have
witnessed a number of foreign fighters
sporting trains for ukraine
ukraine claims that about twenty
thousand have already joined the fight
but that number is hard to verify
those who want to get into ukraine queue
here at passport control we meet nicolas
the financial consultant from france
doesn't want us to show his face
he says he couldn't stand seeing russia
bombing civilians and europe's hesitant
response
i saw a children dying
on tv
and they say
we are doing nothing so i have to go
do you have any experience in fighting
no i don't have any combat experience at
all i have a pilot's license that might
be helpful over here if not we will have
two weeks of training and then we will
fight alongside the ukrainians
his neighbor in the queue is dennis from
keith the businessman is just back from
spain where he took his four children to
safety now he's returning to his
hometown and is ready to fight
i'm happy that foreigners are coming to
help us
it puts a smile on our faces
[Music]
and it makes us stronger in our fight
against the aggressors
together they are watching recent
pictures from keith
advancing russian tanks being attacked
by ukrainian forces
rockets shelling destruction
nicolas tells us he would be stupid not
to be afraid as his journey into the war
zone continues
first to live and then to the front
lines knowing that he might never come
back